now on 8 news now week in edition the
nevada state assembly passes a bill
holding police officers more accountable
what changes are included plus a group
of parents want schools to reopen for
in-person instruction with proper safety
guidelines
their concerns about online education
and
a drop in temperatures going into your
work week
8 news now weekend edition starts right
now
now live this is 8 news now
weekend edition
good morning and thank you for joining
us i'm kristen drummond the triple digit
temperatures recently can be
unbearable sally jaramillo tells us when
those temperatures will start to go down
in your most accurate weather now
forecast sally
good morning another hot day across the
region as we compare
yesterday's temperatures so today you're
going to notice that we're going to be
slightly cooler for today yesterday
we reached a high of a hundred and
twelve for today
a hundred and ten is what it's expected
to be our high
that uv index does remain very high
especially around that one o'clock hour
the count 10.5 it's important that you
protect yourself where that sunscreen
wear those sunglasses please be safe out
there temperature wise we're going to be
warm once again we're going to show you
those temperatures
increasing to the triple digit mark
around that 10 a.m start
by noon a high of 105 and around at
three o'clock hour we expect some south
winds staying 11 miles per hour
with a few gusts up to 18 miles per hour
coming up my full forecast
we'll be talking more about these dry
conditions the slight relief you can see
and where the monsoon of moisture is
back to you all right definitely need to
keep
that sunscreen handy the nevada assembly
passes a bill
seeking to hold police officers more
accountable it includes
several changes including limiting the
use of choke holds
orco mana has the details in a
bipartisan vote saturday night the
nevada assembly passed ab3
the police reform bill it limits the use
of chokeholds and requires more
intervention and reporting
when it comes to use of force incidents
while some believe it's a good step in
the right direction
others say it's either too restrictive
or it's not good enough
there are 38 eyes for nays nevada
legislators prioritizing police reform
ab-3 effectively bans officers from
using choke holes although lawmakers
clarified there are exceptions for
self-defense
i don't want to give the impression that
a chokehold could never be used
other key parts of the bill include
requiring an officer to intervene if
another officer uses unjustified
physical force and requiring that action
to be reported
mandating drug and alcohol testing on
officers who are involved in shootings
and allowing the public to record law
enforcement activity
assembly bill 3 in front of you is the
embodiment of what
we can do better in the state of nevada
because if we aren't moving forward
we're standing still
which means we are falling behind metro
police in support of the bill as an
agency
we're always looking to improve our
policy and
do what's best practices across the
country others in law enforcement
in opposition why is it that suspects
that
die in police custody always end up on
the ground prior to their death
the answer is simple they resisted
arrest some criminal justice advocates
saying the bill only covers the bare
minimum
i could be for this bill but
unfortunately it is not strong enough
ab3 was discussed in the senate as well
but some had problems with the process
it takes a long time to really get a
good bill worked out
this has been rushed the bill passed
through the senate committee of the hole
and will now go to the full senate for a
vote
reporting in the newsroom orco mana 8
news now
one person is dead and another is
recovering after a
shooting it happened around three
yesterday morning near east sahara and
sloan
metro found a man inside a home that was
he was shot in that home was being
rented out for a party
he was pronounced dead at the scene
detectives say another man who was hurt
took himself to the hospital
anyone with information is asked to call
crime stoppers
where you can remain anonymous
we turn now to the latest on corona
virus cases since the pandemic started
there are nearly a thousand new cases
from friday bringing total cases to 49
thousand in nevada
two people passed away bringing the
total deaths to 832
most of the reported new cases are from
here in clark county
80 percent of those who've caught the
virus here locally
have recovered unlv's covet 19 testing
site is
moving it will now be at the thomas and
mack center
it will open next week and testing will
be every tuesday through saturday
from 8 to 4. a group of parents are
advocating for students to go back to
the classroom
with strict safety guidelines this month
parents rallied outside the somerset
academy skypoint campus yesterday
to share their message the clark county
school district plans for all students
to start the school year with
only distance education rally organizers
say they're worried children won't get a
good enough education
or learn social as well as emotional
skills
cdc and the american pediatric
association they have put out lists
of reasons why it is so beneficial for
our kids to be in school
and i think that we should listen to
them parents and teachers at the rally
say with proper health and safety
guidelines
they believe schools should open back up
school officials say their reopening
plan decisions
are all about protecting students
unlv adding a temporary per credit
surcharge on student accounts that will
be in effect for the next school year
the charge is six dollars per credit
hour for undergraduate courses
and eight dollars per credit hour for
graduate courses
the charge is because of the economic
impact of coping 19
on the nevada system of higher education
governor steve sisilak signed an
emergency declaration extending
previously issued directives
that were set to expire friday so that
means businesses must run at 50
occupancy no more than 50 people can't
attend a gathering
bars pubs and taverns in certain
counties including clark
must remain closed alternative ways to
hold public meetings must also be in
place
nevada moves away from phases and now
implements a long-term mitigation
strategy
tomorrow up next a bill that could help
landlords and tenants resolve
disputes without getting the courts
involved plus
nonprofits helping homeowners with
eviction concerns
what help they're offering
from el pollo loco
you're watching the valley's news leader
with bianca holman
sally jeremiah and john treach
this is 8 news now weekend edition
nevada lawmakers are discussing a bill
related to the eviction moratorium
that may help landlords and tenants
resolve disputes
the alternative dispute resolution
program would allow both parties resolve
problems on their own without
direct involvement from the courts the
victim moratorium will be lifted next
month and
nevada supreme court justice james
hardesty who presented the bill says
courts will be unable to deal with the
high number of eviction cases
the eviction problem facing this state
presents enormous hardships for
landlords
as well as their tenants
and this is a step that we hope the
court system
can initiate to try to mitigate those
hardships
legal aid of southern nevada says
they've been getting hundreds of calls
from people worried about getting
evicted
courts will have 30 days to put the
alternative dispute resolution program
in place
if the bill passes there would be a stay
on eviction proceedings during that time
the eviction moratorium being lifted
could cause a lot of problems for many
people
kate houston tells us about a local
non-profit offering homeowners help
during this time nevada help
group is offering homeowners some
assistance as they navigate the
foreclosure process
the nonprofit tells me the number of
foreclosures statewide
could double if not triple once the
moratorium is lifted
the folks that misunderstood what it
meant to take a forbearance on their
payments and then all of a sudden they
get
several payments accelerated if they
couldn't make one month what does it
look like to make several
nevada help group is preparing for the
build up of potential foreclosures due
to the economic fallout from kovid 19.
it's going to fall on the little guy the
middle class hard worker that's trying
to
you know pay for their home they want
homeowners to know what options are
available no matter the situation
even if they happen to be upside down on
their property we've gotten really good
at doing short sales maybe they have a
death in the family
the team will start by reviewing the
homeowner situation
the client can get help filling out
paperwork receive advice from real
estate attorneys
and get resources on how to buy more
time the team
tries to exhaust every retention option
to help the individual keep their home
if it becomes that it's not a
possibility we want to make sure that
we can match them up with potential
buyers to get the
most out of their property nevada help
group wants to give families more
authority
saying banks will not look out for their
best interest we believe that the
lenders have professionals on their side
it's only fair that fam
families have professionals on theirs
kate houston 8 news now
nevada help group offers these services
in english as well as spanish
you can find more information on the
non-profit on eightnewsnow.com
well coming up in sports the las vegas
lights play their home opener without
fans
we'll have highlights and hear from the
players about the new normal
plus very hot and dry conditions
dominated the month of july in vegas
resulting in the seventh warmest july on
record
plus how the rest of the week is shaping
up in your most accurate forecast stay
with us
and we'll see you all again next week
now live this is 8 news now
weekend edition and as the heat
continues for today we do want to give
you some tips to beat the
heat i want to remind you that if you're
suffering from
air conditioning problems want to close
those blinds close those computer
laptops that will keep your house cool
also want to remind you to think of your
pets please think of your children as
well
and everybody you love when the
temperature is 106 that sidewalk feels
like it's 155 degrees for your furry
friends
today's highs will show you a hundred
and ten is what we can expect
normal conditions of one of four the
good news is although we are staying
above normal
six degrees there there is no record
number like 115
back in 1979 those lows will be of 86
degrees for today so you could see
a little bit cooler than what we had
yesterday satellite radar we're still
tracking that hot heat
pushing through because of that ridge of
high pressure over the southwest states
that will
keep us extremely dry the next couple of
days and if you're asking where is the
monsoonal moisture
well that's all going to be staying
towards the east of us mohave county
does have another chance to see some
thunderstorm activity
on wednesday nothing for the las vegas
valley unfortunately
your wind speeds we do have a few
breezes for today similar to what we had
yesterday excuse me
we have a few gusts up to 18 miles per
hour nothing criteria level
and we're also tracking a trough that's
going to be pushing towards the western
states
and that will give us the ability to get
some slight relief so for today around
10 am triple digits around two o'clock
108 and then six o'clock that high
of 109 but the next few days we can see
those temperatures
decreasing you can see 109 on monday 108
on tuesday before we
get back to our normal conditions of 103
and 104 to end the week
for the mountains for today those highs
will be of 85 degrees south wind staying
5 to 15 miles per hour red rock please
take
plenty of water that high will be of one
or two lakes meade showing you those
highs of 107
sunshine and heat for today south winds
staying 5 to 15 miles per hour
and those lows for tonight will be of 84
degrees a clear night with very calm
winds
here is your sally j's seven-day
forecast where we do show you lots
of sunshine hot temperatures pushing
through
until midweek and then after we do have
some slight relief with a high of 103
those lows in the mid
70s back to you well with a high of 111
degrees
day shelters are open to help the
valley's most vulnerable
the salvation army on owens near stalker
street and the shade tree near owens in
maine
will stay open through august and
september health safety protocols as
well as guidelines will be in place
just ahead in sports the golden knights
are preparing to compete for the stanley
cup
how they're preparing plus what the
players have to say when
we come back